to the second fatal crash here in the
valley on Decatur right near Desert Inn
a pedestrian was hit and then pronounced
deceased at the hospital police are
investigating the cause of the crash as
well and Sasha Loftus is Live From The
Scene now joining us with more
information Sasha
Brian you can still see
Desert Inn
dead after this crash that happened a
few hours ago near this intersection now
police tell us around seven tonight
someone called 9-1-1 saying a person was
driving recklessly on Decatur near
Spring Mountain they say that driver
lost control hit several light poles and
then a pedestrian that person was taken
to the hospital where they later died
police say it's possible the driver and
passenger in that car were quote
overdosing we're also told the driver
will face charges just unclear what
those charges are at this time now back
out here live as for road closures you
can see a big portion of Decatur is
closed in each Direction here between
Desert Inn and Spring Mountain the
investigation is underway detectives are
unseen should be closed for a little
while longer so I would avoid the area
if you can if you're driving in this
area at all tonight reporting live
tonight social Loftus 8 News Now